If an entertainers finds success as a musician,
it only makes sense they try their hand at
acting.
There are some entertainers like Janet Jackson
and Frank Sinatra who are known for their
music but started out as actors.
Others emerge as musicians and transition
to film and television.
Here are the 10 Most Amazing Musicians Turned
Actors of all Time.
Queen Latifah
In the late 80s Queen Latifah was making her
way as a rapper and hip hop star following
her days beat boxing on the streets.
After the release of her successful album
“All Hail the Queen” the artist formerly
known as Dana Owens took a swing at acting
and managed to hit some home runs.
After appearing on a few episodes of shows
like The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air, Latifah
had a starring role on the Fox sitcom Living
Single which lasted five seasons while she
was also making her way to the big screen.
Since then she has been in countless films
and even received an Academy Award nomination
for her stellar performance in Chicago which
demonstrated her acting and musical talents.
All Hail the queen.
Harry Connick Jr.
In the 80s Harry Connick Jr. came out with
music showcasing his Sinatra-like crooning
ability.
He made a name for himself with not only his
first album but also his Grammy winning compilation
for the When Harry Met Sally Soundtrack.
He was the handsome jazz musician that made
everyone’s mom swoon.
Making the hearts of the elderly skip a beat
was not enough.
Harry delved into acting with Memphis Belle
in 1990.
It wasn’t until his high profile roles in
Copycat and Independence Day that proved his
film appearances were not a fluke.
He was wildly charming in Hope Floats opposite
Sandra Bullock and used his velvet voice to
narrate My Dog Skip.
He gained a spot as a judge on American Idol
in 2010 but now that the show is over, Connick
can dedicate his time to what he does best;
utilizing his charisma on the big screen.
Barbra Streisand
Barbra Streisand is a legendary performer
with dozens of studio albums.
She started out singing in nightclubs and
earning minor roles on Broadway.
After releasing her first album in 1963 she
emerged a star.
After a few years of sharing her musical talents
with the world, she starred in Funny Girl
and Hello Dolly proving her acting talent
was just as flawless as her singing voice.
The 1970s were a busy time for Babs with memorable
work in A Star is Born and the classic romance
The Way We Were.
Her talents have resulted in numerous awards
including multiple Academy Awards for both
her music and acting.
In recent years she has only sporadically
worked in film and when she does, she goes
for the questionable comedies but that doesn’t
detract from her full wattage talent and her
legendary status.
Will Smith
Will Smith is one of the best examples of
a talented musician turned actor but acting
did not always come naturally to the Fresh
Prince.
After releasing hits like “Parents Just
Don’t Understand” and “Summer Time”,
NBC decided to make a sitcom loosely based
on Smith’s life.
In the early years of The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air, it was apparent that Smith was unsure
how to hit a mark or how to avoid mouthing
other actor’s lines but he pushed through
and became not only a television star but
a monumental movie star.
The 90s brought the box office hits like Independence
Day and Men in Black, but the 2000s brought
the critical acclaim with Ali and The Pursuit
of Happyness.
Smith still occasionally releases music but
barely compared to his serious dedication
to acting.
Since he is able churn out one exceptional
performance after another, the kid from Philly
can do whatever he wants.
Meat Loaf
Meat Loaf is known for his powerful voice
and theatrical music.
In the early 1970s he debuted as the beefy
musician with a funny name and a dramatic
musical presence.
The 70s and 80s were a time of exploring his
acting bug with his first film, appropriately
a musical, The Rocky Horror Picture Show and
a few supporting roles in smaller films.
Meatloaf began racking up film credits in
the 1990s with solid performances in Black
Dog, The Mighty and Fight Club.
He has only since gathered more acting work
with no signs of quitting.
Ludacris
Musician turned actor Ludacris was a case
of someone being far too charming to only
stick to the airwaves.
Ludacris first emerged in the late 90s as
a rapper and his popularity only grew in the
early 2000s.
His career took a turn for the best with acting
roles in 2 Fast 2 Furious, Hustle and Flow
and Crash.
Ludacris takes on mostly supporting roles
in ensemble films but still manages to stand
out amongst a cast of bigger names.
He found a home with the Fast films as the
mouthy Tej Parker cementing his likability
as a supporting player.
Ludacris continues to release music regularly
but his acting has given him a name for those
who were unaware of his music.
He may not be as major of an actor as some
of the others on our list, but to say that
the man isn’t talented would just be ludicrous.
Justin Timberlake
With his ramen noodle hairstyle and loose
fitting white tank top, there was a time when
Justin Timberlake was every tweens favorite
member of Nsync.
Even before he was a mousketeer on The New
Mickey Mouse Club where he was singing his
prepubescent heart out, he was testing the
waters of acting.
Once Timberlake went solo, he not only proved
what everyone knew to be true, he was a legitimate
musician amongst a sea of boy bad members
of the late 90s.
Taking the music world by storm was not enough
for Timberlake, it was time to dive back into
the acting world and somehow he accomplished
it with great aplomb.
From his devastating performance in Alpha
Dog, to his cocky role in The Social Network
to Friends with Benefits which confirmed his
ability to play an impeccable romantic lead.
Timberlake’s ability to jump back and forth
between acting and singing is justified by
his talent.
Cher
Cher started her career as a solo artist in
the mid-1960s performing many covers and gracing
the Billboard charts.
It was her pairing with Sonny Bono that helped
her rise to pop stardom.
The duo had already been a married for a while,
as Cher was a teenage bride, when they released
the smash hit “I Got You Babe” a song
that is still considered one of the best pop
songs ever.
After a few iterations of Sonny and Cher variety
shows, and a few popular solo albums, Cher
went the acting route in the 1980s.
Her work in Silkwood, Moonstruck and Mask
made it obvious that she was more than just
a talented singer, the diva was a fantastic
actress who holds audience’s attention every
time she is onscreen.
Jennifer Hudson
Compared to the other artists on our list,
Jennifer Hudson is a relatively new performer.
She was first introduced to audiences showing
off her phenomenal voice on American Idol.
Despite the fact that she only came in 7th
place on the reality competition show, she
has become one of the most successful contestants
in the show’s history.
Her soulful voice was not her only talent
but it certainly helped her get an integral
role in the film adaptation of Dreamgirls.
She belted out familiar songs while demonstrating
her natural acting talent.
That first acting gig not only earned her
an Academy Award but a multitude of other
accolades.
Hudson continues to show off her acting chops
in films and has segued to stage, making her
Broadway debut in the revival of The Color
Purple.
Jennifer Hudson’s career is evidence that
losing can sometimes lead to winning.
Mark Wahlberg
As much as Mark Wahlberg may want everyone
to forget about his musical career, he actually
did hit the Billboard charts twice back when
he was part of Marky Mark and the Funky Bunch.
Wahlberg made his departure from mediocre
rapper to accomplished actor with small roles
in The Basketball Diaries opposite Leonardo
DiCaprio and quickly landed a lead role in
1996’s Fear as the demented boyfriend of
Reese Witherspoon.
His performance was memorable but it was his
role as Dirk Diggler in Boogie Nights that
made everyone forget about his pants-dropping
earlier career routine.
Wahlberg has proven himself as a strong actor
since then and while he probably shouldn’t
be embarrassed about his music past, audiences
are certainly pleased he traded in his mic
for an acting chair.
There you have it.
What do you think of our list?
Who did we forget?
Let us know in the comments.
Don’t forget to subscribe to the Screen
Rant channel to see more videos like this
one